the readies to create the self-driving
car continues at a feverish pace with
major players pumping billions into the
effort and the intense pursuit may have
led to corporate corporate rather
espionage this week former uber engineer
anthony levin dosti was charged with 33
counts of trade secret theft accused of
bringing key data from google to rival
uber self-driving vehicles are a
frequent subject on the courts news
website and we're the topic of the
site's obsession email this week here to
talk about it is Kevin Dulaney
editor-in-chief and co-ceo of courts
Kevin good morning good morning well in
court says recent news letter on the
topic it's said quote as the technology
and transportation policy stands
autonomous vehicles are poised to
deliver either transportation heaven or
hell so which is it so right now we're
heading towards hell and there are two
reasons for this the first reason is
that these cars are not safe yet enough
you know there are five levels of
autonomous vehicle safety according to
the US government certification we're
now at best were of about level two and
what this means is that people need to
be keeping their hands on the wheel they
may be keeping alert to avoid accidents
the second reason that we're headed
towards hell is what researchers have
found is that when people have access to
less cards driving that requires less
effort and money they actually drive a
lot more so the traffic that we
experience today is likely to get a lot
worse if without we're taking some
measures to include carpooling and other
things we just let these cars go how do
we pull ourselves out of hell what
should the industry doing both to
reassure people and also to change the
way it's developing on top yeah so there
is actually a path for autonomous
vehicles that actually is a good path
and there are two key parts of it the
first is that it is introduced in kind
of in waves and the way this makes sense
is like low speed buses for example or
or truck platooning is actually one of
the applications that people think you
actually have a human driver driving one
truck any of an autonomous truck behind
it so you can effectively double the
double the the capacity of it yeah and
then the other key thing is carpooling
and so if you make it easier for people
to drive because you could sleep or do
whatever while your car is driving we
need to make sure that it looks more
like uber pool than uber X so people get
in cars together otherwise the
congestion is going to be atrocious you
mentioned that congestion so along those
lines it's City Planning it's also
policy of they're just it seems that
there we don't have the policies and the
regulations that's right how does that
shift yeah well so what we see currently
is that there's not a lot of guidance
there's not coming out of Washington
there's not enough and this is like a
lot of other areas of policy and
politics where our lawmakers are
struggling and our current
administration is actually struggling to
take the lead here and so what we're
seeing is that it's actually the car
makers and the tech companies who are
involved in this area themselves who are
pooling data who are starting to
collaborate a lot more on some of the
safety things that need to be done we I
think it's in all of our interest that
our governments actually get more
involved and get in front of this we
haven't actually seen that yet yeah it's
it's another area it seems like we're
technology is way ahead and we've got to
play catch-up no never sleeping drivers
behind so right we all that we saw that
I bet so that's a long time in the
future Kevin thank you